[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
right here's the challenge your goal is
to burn 10 000 calories in 30 days and
you're going to burn an average of 340
calories every single day through
exercising so today's workout is going
to be a high intensity cardio based
circuit to get your heart rate pumping
and trust me your muscles will be on
fire there will be a total of three
circuits so the first circuit will be
based on lower body second circuit upper
body and the final circuit will work on
your core
you got to get your body warmed up and
let's do this
[Music]
right so start marching on the spot okay
you got to get your body warmed up so
each circuit will be for 45 seconds long
with 15 seconds rest in between remember
if you struggle take it down take it a
notch down and breathe and get back into
the workout your goal is to complete the
workout all right good keep marching we
want to do a really quick warm-up and
now let's go jumping jacks very good
so this is just to get your muscles
ready and also to stretch out a little
bit forget the blood flowing in your
body very nice place your breathing good
Breathe In Breathe Out stretch and reach
very nice
and now let's just jog on the spot all
right
as you jog slowly bring your knees up
nice high knees good tap it
and now just keep jogging all right so
the first workout will be a jump squat
with toe touches so jump and tap all
right again 45 seconds long if you
struggle you can always start with
normal Squat and tap got that right
first workout First Circuit first
exercise let's go down jump tap jump and
touch good so remember to squat deep
very good
again remember this workout is for
everybody so if you find that this is
challenging you can always start without
a jump tap twist your body and touch
your toes very good
nice
keep going
squat deep feel your glutes feel your
legs feel every fiber of your muscles
nice keep going jump tap
good
few more
last one more
and
rest it out second workout all right
it's going to be a lunch
I want you to step forward step back
lunge and bring your knee up that's it
okay if you want to challenge yourself
then you can lunge and add a hop ready
let's give a step forward lunge add a
hop
back
hop and back it's just a really small
hop but that will activate your quads
your glutes and your calves even more
good lunge and half nice let's just
focus on one side to begin with keep
going you're halfway there small hop
tiptoe
feel the right leg working
lunge back whoa
my heart is Raising
and I'm panting and you should be
breathing real hard as well keep going
last few more last one
and
check it out March it on your favorite
workout burpees with high knees okay
take this five second really rest right
let's go down
give me
nice burpees out in and
two up good down
high knees
good down again
burpees have burpees and high up good
let's keep going down
and up very good
down
and up
nice double high knee
one and two down
up whoa I can hear you scream let's go
not stop now and up
down again
you're strong okay every workout will
only make you stronger up
and rest in our final workout is going
to be a new to squat all right good so
you can start down here and hop into a
squat get back down and hop all right
let's go rest it out and power up use
your legs okay first circuit is all
about your leg power up and down good
push it up nice use your core engage
your core and hop into a squat there you
go remember as you squat lift your body
up do not hunch forward
keep going
bring it down
hop
down
hop
down
hop very good keep going you're more
than halfway there you only have 10
seconds left
down
up hop good down hop up and one last one
hop up and Shake It Out rest it out okay
we want to repeat the entire circuit
once more so again the first workout is
a jump squat with toe touch okay again
if you find this to be challenging you
can always start with basic squat so you
can always start with basic Squat and
tap Squat and tap as you progress get
into a jump so let's go jump tap jump
and tap good tap up and tap
very nice
look straight ahead open up your chest
twist your hips twist your waist feel
your inner and your outer thighs working
together nice high good up
tap high up tap
keep going high up tap
last few more
you got this I know you're strong
and I want to see your sweat dripping
rest it out next lunge with a knee lift
okay so start on your left leg now right
leg back
all right let's go let's get down into a
lunge
as you come up you want to add a little
bit of hop all right let's go down hop
nice lunge down and hop remember small
movement but really effective workout on
your legs small
and burst into a small hop nice hop it
up
good feel your left leg working now keep
going lunge back hop
lunch bag and hop you're more than
halfway there stay strong it's all about
muscle contraction it's all about
targeting one leg at a time very nice
keep going keep hopping do not stop
right now you have one more and rest it
out
right
breathe burpees with two high knees okay
ready five seconds rest breathe in
breathe out and
let's not waste time let's go burpees up
two good down
come on show me your athletic side good
let's keep going high up
down half burpees and up nice land
gently
and high up
breathe
remember Every Breath You Take you're
pushing yourself that a little further
and I want to see your sweat dripping on
the floor or on the mat
let's go I told you this is going to be
an high intensity workout let's go last
one
hurry up
one more
breath in
all right get down onto the floor good
new to squat okay
remember focus on proper form find a
second and you will get a one minute
break let's go new
hopped into a squad good work on your
legs work on your core down
oh up down again
push it up nice use your core lift
yourself up
burst
good breathe
keep going halfway there
wanna find a workout
for the first circuit okay and you will
get a one minute rest and we have two
more
circuits let's go
you can slow down but do not stop down
up give me one more down up
and
oh
rest it up
one minute break
take this time to hydrate yourself wipe
your sweat and the second circuit will
be focusing on your upper body and also
cardio
rest
[Music]
you have 20 seconds left okay my sweat
will not stop tripping and my heart rate
is still high up so the goal is to keep
your heart rate high up in order to burn
more calories the second circuit we'll
be focusing more on your upper body so
we want to start with push-ups with
shoulder tap okay and then we will
progress right let's go let's start with
push up one push-up shoulder tap left
right down okay again beginners you can
always start on your knees and the goal
is to move to not move your hips too
much okay minimal movement tighten your
core Left Right One Tap good 45 seconds
let's go down up tap
feel your upper body working
very good down left right tap
good he's your breathing
very good memories in and breathe out
nice give me last three more tap
last two more tap
one more down
tap and rest
second workout playing Jacks with knee
hops all right so two plank Jacks with
one knee hop all right so again it's all
about starting in a plank position to
strengthen your upper body so let's get
down
double plank jacks and one knee hop out
in and to your side
dip in and to your slide that's it okay
so this is another cardio movement to
bring your heart rate back up
so out in
forward and back good
double and single
I can see my sweat dripping
you should see your sweat dripping as
well keep going
piece of breathing bring your heart rate
back up
nice in out
let's go
feel your abs Contracting as you tuck
your knees in
contract
and rest it up oh my God right let's
work more on your arms so let's get down
into a opposite Plank and let's do
tricep dips okay so again this is small
movement bring your elbows close
together your butt up dip and bring it
down that's it small targeted movement
but you will really feel on your triceps
remember both elbows should be pointed
back almost touching the floor and bring
it back up
sometimes it's not about big movements
but rather small movement to really
Target specific muscles good bring it
down up push your elbows back okay do
not spread your elbows up lift your toes
off if you want to bring it down up and
feel your triceps burning very good
keep going I can feel my triceps oh tone
up those bingo Wings let's go last one
one more and rest it out and the final
workout for this second is your typical
mountain climbers okay mountain climbers
will really work on your core and also
your hips right let's go bring it in and
climb all right good remember the goal
is to keep your back flat okay this is
wrong avoid this movement all right back
flat in a high Plank and bring your
knees tuck your knees in and imagine
that you're sprinting or you're raising
let's go let's bring it in climb in
tuck your knee as close in as you can to
your chest keep climbing
do not stop right now remember we
finished our workout okay we go right to
the end see your sweat dripping Pace
your breathing
and keep going strong you got five
seconds left come on let's speed it up
let's go and
rest in out
see this sweat this is hard work all
right let's move on to the second round
you got five seconds left wipe your
sweat or let it drip push up with
shoulder tap
let's go push up tap left right
down and up left right good up and down
tap it out
nice minimal hip movements okay
good down
and left and right keep your upper body
strong ladies we tend to neglect on our
upper body let's go work on your chest
pump it up firm then up down and up very
good keep going 15 seconds left
stay strong stay with me out and in
come on guys last two more push up tap
let's go one more down up rest it out
okay take this time to really breathe
wipe your sweat I look like a crazy
person but I'm feeling damn strong all
right so you don't stop now let's get
into playing Jacks with knee hops right
let's start into a plank position let's
go out and in double tuck it in good
double out and in tuck it and crunch
your abs lift your butt up Crunch and
bring your knees towards your chest
crunch good so the goal is to work on
your apps and your car right here and
when you maintain a high plank you will
also be working on your arms good let's
go
double plank Jack and one knee hop
crunching good keep going
crunching
give me two more right two more only two
more
crunch it in last one more
double
crunch it in and double
and rest it up all right reverse plank
four triceps deep okay
oh
this sweat is real I'm not stopping
right now and you're not stopping as
well let's lift your butt up elbows
point to back small dibs and work on
your triceps work on those bingo wings
those flabby arms okay do not neglect
them good small bring your butt close to
the mat and push it back up okay
it's like your belly in tighten your
core and push using your arms not using
your butt all right good you're halfway
there your triceps should be on fire
keep going nice down and up down and up
good
keep focusing if your arms are shaking
that is absolutely fine that means your
muscles are Contracting and you are
working on them last two seconds
and
final no-nonsense workout mountain
climbers okay so back into a high plank
as fast as you can or as slow as you can
take yourself but remember do not stop
this is your final workout for this
second circuit let's go up and climb it
up knee to your chest okay relax your
shoulders
keep your arms straight focus on
bringing your knees to your chest and
crunch feel your abs through your heart
pumping
and just keep climbing
Focus guys
see a sweat dripping that is your fat
crying and that's your hard work you
will never regret a workout you do you
will thank yourself later on let's keep
going 10 seconds left to a solid one
minute break I feel you okay I feel you
last few more
and
ah
good rest it out seconds I get done okay
one more second focusing on your core
and also your cardio so wipe your strap
clear yourself hydrated and we want to
move on to the final second
[Music]
thank you
20 more seconds for you to breathe okay
find a circuit focusing on core and
cardio I am sweating through my pants my
spots bra everything and I want you to
be as sweaty as I am alright so get down
onto the mat we want to start with v-tax
okay so just place your pumps on the mat
just to support your upper body keep
your legs straight your toes straight
and up and down good okay so V tucks
keeping your legs straight tuck it feel
your lower abs working tuck it in good
up and down targeting on your core
crunching in and focusing especially on
your hips and your lower abs good keep
tucking it in good as much as you can
keep your legs straight your toes
pointed forward crunch in nice control
down do not let it drop control and nice
and control good you got it you're
almost there crunch it in this is your
first workout for the final circuit
crunching last one more and rest it out
right the second workout is going to be
a walking plank to Spiderman okay so we
want to start right at the corner of
your mat and we want to walk to the end
and then give me a Spider-Man crunch
okay let's go start with one crunch one
Spiderman let's walk walk walk and
remember keep your body flat all the
time two Spidermans okay we want to keep
increasing the crunches walk back
keeping your body straight three
two
three
nice let's walk back this workout is
really good for your obliques give me
four now one
two
three
four last one more
and let's bring it up two five let's go
one
two
rested on you're lucky right there okay
the next workout will be growing this so
this is a love-hate relationship
it's really good for your legs your
thighs your core but it is torture okay
so into a plank start with your left and
your left arm hop into your right hop
and change okay open up your thighs open
up your inner thighs open up your chest
look up and feel your legs your core and
also your arms working good hop and look
beginners if you want to take a step
take a step back take a step forward
okay as you progress alternate and hop
good whoo
feel your heart rate
pumping let's go point for your inner
thighs working your glutes and your legs
keep going take a few more I told you
this is a love hate relationship one
more and rest it out okay final workout
Sprints at high knees okay let's finish
with a high knee and a Sprint so get
back up stand back up I want you to work
on your cardio right now three seconds
left it's all about sprinting and let's
go Sprint as fast as you can small quick
leg movement keep going tiptoe spring
work on your entire body work on your
entire core and just let it rain keep
looking ahead okay imagine you're a
sprinter and you want to give me your
best timing speed it up keep your elbows
relaxed your shoulders relaxed and keep
sprinting
keep going guys keep pushing in 15
seconds left right tiptoe
keep going guys you have less than 10
seconds okay as fast as you can right
now tiptoe Sprint
come on breathe in last two last one and
rest it out
you are not done okay that was the first
four minutes your final four minutes so
let's get down all right let's get into
knee vitax okay your favorite let's go
support the upper body and let's go tuck
it in straight legs point and go nice
and easy remember your arms are just to
support your upper body work on your
lower abs your core and work on your
hips to bring your legs up and to Crunch
it in very good bring it in and down
nice slow and controlled movements okay
don't rush it nice and controlled good
ah breathe if you feel like shaking that
is absolutely fine you have worked
really hard so everything should be
shaking crunch nice nice and controlled
crunch relax your shoulders crunch last
five more seconds crunch it in last one
more and give me one more and rest it
out okay next walking plank with
Spiderman okay so start at the corner of
your mat five seconds left guys okay
give me a nice solid Spiderman let's go
high up Spiderman
and let's walk keeping your back flat
your entire body in a straight line two
crunch it in
walk back
nice and controlled
small movement give me three one
two
three
walk it back
nice and control minimal movement on
your body four
two
three
knee four
walk it back
and the final one
let's go
keep going
to the end of the timer good
rest it out and third workout groiness
okay
I need lots of concentration for this
okay let's go hi plank ready right leg
and let's go opposite side opposite Hop
look up
opening up chest place your breathing
nice
flip those ponytails good come on keep
hopping
feel your sweat dripping final second
workout keep going okay everybody needs
a starting point if you're struggling
you can always step back and step back
okay I feel your burn I feel your pain
keep going
do not stop I am struggling but I am not
stopping keep going relax your shoulders
feel the bounce contract your core push
your legs back last two more
last one more
and rest it out
oh my God up guys get back up get back
up into a Sprint okay your final workout
your final workout and you are done you
will be burning 300 over calories let's
go sprints let's keep going
step forward a little bit Sprint
breathe and Like A Champion okay you
don't stop now you finish the workout
Like A Champion keep going tiptoe spring
work on your entire body work on your
entire core and just let it rain let's
go
half way there keep sprinting
breathe breathe real hard because you
know what you have 10 seconds left let's
go speed it up guys come on speed it up
your final circuit your final exercise
and you deserve a good break
wow
wherever you are right now I want you to
breathe and give me a big high five you
have done so well that was a 30 minute
solid hit cardio workout focusing on
your upper body your lower body your
core and you must be sweating through
your pants through your butt through
your spots bruh through everything okay
well done guys so remember the challenge
is to burn 10 000 calories in 30 days
every single day if you can fit this
workout in or alternate it with another
workout burn at least
340 calories every single day it is not
difficult it is very possible the goal
is to keep moving and keep moving and
you only get better alright you got that
10 000 calories in 30 days don't forget
to give this video a thumbs up because
you have finished the workout share this
on with your friends get them to join
you in this challenge subscribe to my
YouTube channel if you haven't yet done
it and check out a lot more crazy
workout challenges crazy fitness
workouts healthy recipes and fitness
tips to guide you through your workout
ah Let It Rain and then hop into the
shower and start your day right all the
best